[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Serien einen schönen guten Abend
zusammen Christian heute gab es ein
dfb-krisengipfel und sogar schon ein
Ergebnis später mehr guten Abend wir
schauen uns gemeinsam den
themenüberblick an
großrazia gegen Reichsbürger bundesweit
wurden 25 Verdächtige festgenommen die
offenbar planten das politische System
zu stürzen
ein Jahr Ampelkoalition ein
fortschrittsbündnis will die
Bundesregierung sein aber im ersten Jahr
überwiegt Krisenmanagement
und Flick bleibt trotz Vorrunden aus bei
der Fußball-WM in Katar wird der
Bundestrainer nicht abgelöst
[Musik]
wir beginnen die Sendung mit einer der
größten Razzien die es bislang in
Deutschland gab im Morgengrauen
durchgeführt in der reichsbürgersszene
hob die Polizei eine rechte mutmaßliche
Terrorgruppe aus die offenbar plante
gewaltsam die Bundesregierung zu stürzen
was vielleicht wird klingt ist nach
ersten Erkenntnissen ernst zu nehmend
organisiert worden die Innenministerin
spricht von einem Abgrund
terroristischer Bedrohung Alexandra
vacan überrichtet es ist 6 Uhr an diesem
Mittwochmorgen als mit schwerem Gerät
ein Einsatz beginnt der bislang wohl zu
den größten des Landes zählt 3000 Beamte
die in insgesamt 11 Bundesländern aber
auch im österreichischen Kitzbühel wie
auch in Perugia Italien etwa 150 Häuser
Wohnungen Büros durchsuchen und
insgesamt 25 Personen festnehmen beim
Bundesgerichtshof in Karlsruhe werden
sie zurzeit vorgeführt ihr Ziel ein
gewaltsamer Staatsstreich so die
Vermittler die Vereinigung hat sich nach
unseren Erkenntnissen zum Ziel gesetzt
die bestehende staatliche Ordnung in
Deutschland die freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung und der
Einsatz von Gewalt und militärischen
Mitteln zu beseitigen einzelne
Mitglieder der terroristischen
Vereinigung haben sich nach unserer
Erkenntnis auch mit Überlegungen
getragen
gewaltsam in den Deutschen Bundestag
einzudringen
Umsturzpläne für die sie gezielt
Soldaten und Polizisten rekrutiert und
für die sie Tote in Kauf genommen hätten
und es gab wohl Pläne wer was machen
sollte in einer neuen Regierung die
Ermittlungen lassen in den Abgrund einer
terroristischen Bedrohung aus dem
reichsbürgermilieu blicken
die heute aufgedeckten mutmaßlichen
terroristische Vereinigung ist nach dem
Stand der Ermittlungen von gemeinsamen
Umsturz Fantasien und
Verschwörungsideologien gegründet er
soll ein Rädelsführer der mutmaßlichen
Terrorgruppe gewesen sein Heinrich der
13 Prinz Reus der 71-Jährige Unternehmer
aus Frankfurt am Main soll auch versucht
haben Kontakt nach Russland aufzunehmen
in Moskau heißt es man wissen von nichts
auch in der Gruppe dabei ein aktiver
Soldat des Kommandos Spezialkräfte KSK
in Calw sowie Michael F
exkriminalhauptkommissar aus Hannover
Querdenker inzwischen aus dem Dienst
geklagt und die ehemalige
afd-bundestagsabgeordnete Birgit malsack
winkemann sie arbeitet als Richterin in
Berlin nach der Festnahme aus ihrer
Partei eine Stellungnahme auf der
Homepage wir verurteilen solche
Bestrebungen und lehnen diese
nachdrücklich ab
inzwischen sind 13 der 25 mutmaßlichen
Reichsbürger in Untersuchungshaft
ja noch im Sommer da warnte der
Generalbundesanwalt dass die Szene
sogenannte Reichsbürger immer
gewaltbereiter werde wie aktiv dieses
Szene in Deutschland ist und was sie so
gefährlich macht dazu Antoine kuscheln
Razzia 2016 im bayerischen georgsmünd
ein Spezialeinsatzkommando will die
Waffen eines reichsbürgers sicherstellen
der feuert auf die Polizisten ein
Beamter stirbt wenig später im
Krankenhaus die sogenannten Reichsbürger
haben sich immer mehr radikalisiert im
vergangenen Jahr zählte der
Verfassungsschutzbericht etwa 21.000
Reichsbürger darunter sein rund 2100
gewaltbereit ihr Ziel die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland abschaffen einige behaupten
dass das deutsche Kaiserreich
fortbestehe und dessen Verfassung
weiterhin gültig sei mit Berufung auf
diese Reichsverfassung fordern Sie den
Urenkel des 1918 abgedanken Kaisers
Wilhelm II als deutschen Kaiser
einzusetzen
meistens ist es dann doch so dass dann
eben antisemitische Töne Deutsch
schlagen dann sind es die Rothschilds
beispielsweise die im Hintergrund die
Fäden ziehen würden das ist ja
offensichtlich auch bei dem einem
Adligen der jetzt mit als redelsführer
verhaftet worden ist auch bekannt
geworden dass er offensichtlich der
Meinung ist das ist eine
jüdisch-deutsche juristische
Weltverschwörung geben könnte und das
erinnert natürlich an bittere harte
antisemitische Argumentation und sie
sind immer mehr geworden in den letzten
Jahren unter ihnen auch
Verschwörungstheoretiker der
corona-pandemie das macht sie aber
eigentlich umso gefährlicher weil die
Leute eben noch weniger denken das ist
eine politische Lösung für sie gibt
sondern dass eben jetzt genau die
radikalen Leute die sich verschärft
haben in ihren Positionen denken jetzt
müsste das gewaltsam gelöst werden
Reichsbürger weigern sich Steuern zu
zahlen drucken eigene Pässe und
Geldscheine das Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz stuft sie als Staats-
und dazu jetzt bei uns im Studio die
Rechtsexpertin Sarah Tacke Sarah was
macht diese
Verschwörungstheoretiker die manche als
absurd bezeichnen so gefährlich nach
Ansicht der Bundesanwaltschaft
Bundesanwalt hat es heute sehr gut
beschrieben auf der einen Seite habe ist
den politischen Arm gegeben die diese
neue Staatsform erdacht haben sogar
schon Ministerposten untereinander
aufgeteilt haben sollen klingt absurd
aber gleichzeitig soll es den
militärischen Arm gegeben haben
bestehend aus ehemaligen
Bundeswehrsoldaten die Waffen haben in
Besitz von Waffen wissen wie man mit
Waffen umgeht und genau diese Mischung
macht diese Brisanz aus haben wir
Ermittler gesagt klar ist aber auch von
dem echten staatsstreit waren wir hier
Meilen weit entfernt im Mittel haben mir
gesagt allein an nötigen Waffen hätte es
da gefehlt um hier wirklich ein Umsturz
herbeizuführen nichtsdestotrotz muss man
auch ganz klar sagen dass einige der
mutmaßlichen Terroristen in der Lage
gewesen werden und wohl auch bereit
gewesen wären zu töten und wie sind die
Ermittler eigentlich auf die Spur der
festgenommen gekommen dass
mehrere Landesämter des
Verfassungsschutzes einzelne Personen
beobachtet haben dann festgestellt haben
wir haben es hier mit dem Netzwerk zu
tun und die haben auch den den
übergeordneten Plan hier wirklich die
Bundesregierung die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland aus den Angeln zu heben mit
dem Festnahmen heute muss man aber auch
ganz klar sagen sind die Ermittlungen
noch lange nicht am Ende sie sind erst
am Anfang jetzt muss geklärt werden wie
groß ist diese mutmaßliche terrazelle
und auch wie gefährlich ZDF
Rechtsexpertin sarattacke vielen Dank
für die Hintergründe und zur Thematik
bei uns auch einen zdf-spezial also zur
großrats ja in der reichsbürgerszene es
ist ein Jahr her da lag Aufbruchstimmung
in der Luft als sich SPD Grüne und FDP
gemeinsam an die Regierungsarbeit
machten mehr Fortschritt Wagen so hat
die Ampel ja ihren Koalitionsvertrag
überschrieben und vieles wollten die
drei Parteien nach 16 Jahren
unionsgeführter Regierung anders machen
dann kam der russische Angriff auf die
Ukraine Daniel
kleiner Zwischenbilanz
die Schokoladensorte zum ampeljubiläum
Zartbitter
Schmunzeln allenthalben zart war der
Beginn Aufbruchstimmung wirgefühl dann
eine bittere neue Wirklichkeit und als
Reaktion der Ausruf einer Zeitenwende
all das bildet früh eine neue
Geschäftsgrundlage die zwingt die Grünen
etwas mehr Atomkraft zuzulassen und
deutlich mehr Braunkohle den
Finanzminister zwingt sie Rekord hohe
zusätzliche Kredite aufzunehmen dennoch
jenseits von Haushalt und Schuldenbremse
es ist ein permanenter Stresstest für
alle auch atmosphärisch
dass manche Haltungsnote nicht so gut
gewesen ist wie ich mir das gewünscht
habe das sei dahingestellt aber am Ende
zählt was wir auch geschafft haben
nämlich das Land in einer dramatischen
Krisensituation zusammenzuhalten statt
regieren reagieren so ist es oft oft
notgedrungen in diesem ersten Jahr
manche geplant ist aber wurde umgesetzt
der Mindestlohn etwa auf 12 € erhöht aus
Hartz IV wurde eine Art Hartz 4+ namens
Bürgergeld viel stehen noch an wir
arbeiten jeden Tag sehr hart daran
Deutschland besser zu machen gerade
wegen dieser fürchterlichen Krise in der
wir uns befinden gerade deshalb muss
Deutschland moderner und besser die
Zukunft gehen viele in der Opposition
erkennen an dass der Krieg die
Voraussetzungen massiv verändert habe
aber manchmal hat man das Gefühl sie
drehen hochtourig im Leerlauf kommen zu
keinen Ergebnissen streiten sich sehr
viel und manche Ergebnisse kommen eben
sehr spät für viele Betroffene zu spät
noch nicht zu spät ist es für eine
trendum die derzeit nötig wäre für eine
Wiederwahl aktuell hätte die Ampel dafür
keine Mehrheit gewählt wird geht alles
planmäßig in knapp drei Jahren
wegen der strengen nullcovit-politik in
China hat es in dem Land zuletzt
Proteste wie seit Jahrzehnten nicht mehr
gegeben jetzt hat die Staatsführung eine
Kehrtwende beschlossen ein
Zehn-Punkte-Plan sieht deutlicher
Erleichterungen vor so können infizierte
künftig zu Hause in Quarantäne lockdowns
soll es nur noch lokal begrenzt geben
und auch Reisen wird deutlich einfacher
in die USA dort können die Demokraten
von Präsident beiden einen Monat nach
den sogenannten mit terms noch einen
Erfolg verbuchen bei der Stichwahl um
den Senatsposten in Georgia setzte sich
Amtsinhaber Warnock durch er sichert
seiner Partei so eine knappe Mehrheit im
Senat die Niederlage des
republikanischen Kandidaten Walker gilt
auch als Rückschlag für Ex-Präsident
Trump
und jetzt geht es um nicht weniger als
einen Schlüssel fürs Überleben es geht
um die Rettung der Artenvielfalt im
kanadischen Montreal beginnt heute die
Welt naturschutzkonferenz die sei unsere
Chance diese Orgie der Zerstörung zu
stoppen meint der UN-Generalsekretär das
Ziel ist ehrgeizig bis 2030 soll knapp
ein Drittel der weltweiten Land und
Meeresflächen unter Schutz gestellt
werden innerer Rabe
Schweinswale vor der deutschen
Ostseeküste viele sind es nicht mehr und
sie werden immer weniger inzwischen
stehen in Deutschland mehr als 37
Prozent der Tier- und Pflanzenarten auf
der Roten Liste gelten damit als
gefährdet zu den Verlierern gehören auch
Vögel wie der Kiebitz oder das Rebhuhn
seit 1990 ist ihr Bestand um rund 30%
zurückgegangen der Mensch nimmt ihnen
immer mehr Lebensraum es sind nicht nur
wirklich die ikonischen Tiere wie
Orang-Utan oder Nashörner die für das
Überleben auf dem Planeten wichtig sind
es sind auch Insekten wie Bienen die für
die Bestäubung zuständig sind und damit
auch dafür verantwortlich dass wir genug
zu essen haben
Biodiversität ist mehr als einzelne
Tier- und Pflanzenarten es geht um
vielfältige Ökosysteme die auch der
Mensch dringend braucht auf der
Konferenz in Montreal liegt jetzt ein
Abkommen auf dem Tisch das weltweit 30%
der Land und Meeresfläche unter Schutz
stellt bisher sind es mit sieben Prozent
der Meere und 17% des Landes große Ziele
jetzt fehlen nur noch wirkungsvolle
regeln
deshalb müssen wir auch Kriterien
festlegen was es heißt 30 Prozent unter
Schutzstellung damit wir nicht bei
sogenannten paper-parks landen also
Schutzgebieten die nur auf dem Papier
existieren Gebiete ganz ohne Fischfang
könnte es auch bald vor der deutschen
Küste geben dort sterben weiter
Schweinswale in Fischernetzen und auch
ihr Nahrungsangebot wird immer dürftiger
morgen ist wieder bundesweiter warntag
beim ersten 2020 vielleicht erinnern Sie
sich ist alles schiefgelaufen die
probewarnung die wird über Sirenen im
Fernsehen und Radio verbreitet aber eben
auch über das Handy und bislang gegen
das in Deutschland eigentlich nur wenn
man so spezielle Gefahren Apps
runtergeladen hat aber dieses Mal soll
auch über das sogenannte sell broadcast
System gewarnt werden ganz ohne App
flächendeckend und das ginge dann über
die mehr als 82.000 Funkmasten in
unserem Land und genau auf diese Weise
sind dann auch lokale Warnungen möglich
die Warnmeldung die wird dann als SMS an
alle verschickt die in dem betroffenen
Gebiet in den Funkmasten eingeloggt sind
morgen Vormittag um 11 sollen die
Systeme getestet werden und alles was
wir dazu wissen müssen jetzt von anderen
Stern
morgen Vormittag sollen bundesweit
Sirenen heulen da wo es sie gibt und sie
funktionieren Deutschlands Katastrophen
Schützer Proben den Ernstfall nach dem
Fehlschlag dem disaster vor zwei Jahren
Bund und Länder haben in den vergangenen
Jahren in die Warnsysteme vor allem nach
dem warntag 2020 und den Krisen der
jüngeren Vergangenheit investiert ich
glaube wie gesagt dass das Morgen sehr
erfolgreich sein wird
per SMS wurde der warntag angekündigt
Smartphone Mobilfunk morgen wichtige
Bausteine zum ersten Mal wird
selbroadcast getestet andere Länder
haben das schon längst
laute klare Warnungen ganz ohne App und
Internet das Problem zu alte Handys mit
zu alter Software können die Waren SMS
gar nicht bekommen
wir haben in Deutschland ungefähr eine
Abdeckung von 50 bis 70 Prozent die in
der Lage sind das am 8.12 zu empfangen
und cell broadcast soll erst im Februar
regulär in Betrieb gehen mehr als
eineinhalb Jahre nach der letzten
verheerenden Katastrophe in Deutschland
der todesflut im attertal bei der waren-
und katastrophenschutzsysteme so
dramatisch versagt haben die Frage
Morgen wie groß die wahren Lücken
diesmal sein werden
[Musik]
woanders auch Alarm und zwar echter
Kristin krisengipfelband DFB mit der
Nachricht der Bundestrainer bleibt alles
mit Blick auf die Heim-EM in Deutschland
2024 vor knapp einer Stunde kam die
Meldung Hansi Flick bleibt Bundestrainer
also vorerst kein weiteres Beben am Tag
nach dem Rückzug von Oliver Bierhoff am
Ende eines relativ kurzen Dreier
Treffens mit Blick DFB-Präsident Bernd
Neuendorf und Vize Hans Joachim Watzke
man lässt nun wirklich gar nichts
unversucht beim DFB um nach dieser
verkorksten WM wieder in einem etwas
besseren Licht dazustehen nicht die
einzige passende Metapher heute im
Umfeld der neuen DFB-Zentrale in der die
große Aussprache erwartet wurde nur der
Parkplatz des Präsidenten bleibt leer im
Laufe des Tages sicker durch dass das
Treffen in einem Frankfurter nobel Hotel
stattfindet während andernorts wie hier
in Dortmund die Nationalspieler zum Teil
wieder ins Training eingestiegen sind
nimmt mit Fredi Bobic ein Kandidat auf
die Nachfolge von Oliver Bierhoff nun
erstmals Stellung das ist auf einer
Seite kannst du Ehre seinen Stolz sein
ja ähm und man kann sagen hey
super ja DFB oder gerade Nationalteam
ist immer eine besondere Auszeichnung
aber noch mal ich bin nicht auf der
Suche nach einem Job gewesen Hansi Flick
verlässt gegen 17 Uhr das gemeinsame
Treffen kommentarlos vor einer guten
Dreiviertelstunde dann die Nachricht des
DFB das Flick Bundestrainer bleibt
Horst Büchner in Neu-Isenburg wie
bewertest du die Entscheidung das haben
sie Flick im Amt bleibt
ja so ein Tag der wichtigen
Weichenstellungen doch zunächst war es
ein Tag der Ausweichmanöver denn das
besagte Trio er tauchte nicht beim DFB
auf und dieser geheime Krisengipfel der
dann später gar nicht mehr so geheim war
fand hier in Gravenbruch statt in einem
Hotel um 14:30 Uhr ging es los das ging
dann so bis 17 Uhr und rund 90 Minuten
später kam dann die DFB Presse
Mitteilung fliegt bleibt Bundestrainer
dass er öffentlich zum Rapport bestellt
wurde hat ihm gar nicht gefallen genauso
der Umgang mit Bierhoff ist dem
aufgestoßen nach unseren Informationen
hatte er den Eindruck dass Bierhoff zum
Rücktritt gedrängt wurde aber erwertet
das nicht alles
Vertrauensverlust er macht also weiter
und es gab keinen persönlichen Rückzug
der DFB hat er so weiterhin einen
Bundestrainer aber immer noch keinen
Sportdirektor
vielen Dank für diese Einordnungen
als letztes Team hat sich Portugal fürs
WM-Viertelfinale in Katha qualifiziert
ganz überlegen mit sechs zu eins gegen
die Schweiz absolut beeindruckend mit
drei Treffern WM der pytant Gonzalo
Ramos der 21-Jährige nutzte seine Chance
von Beginn an lief an Stelle des
Kapitäns Cristiano Ronaldo auf der erst
viel später für Ramos eingewechselt
wurde
und Samstagnachmittag geht es dann gegen
das Überraschungsteam aus Marokko weiter
die Nordafrikaner erstmalig unter den
letzten acht der Endrunde durch den
Sensation Sieg gegen Spanien mit 13:0 im
Elfmeterschießen danach Freudentaumel in
Casablanca und vielen europäischen
Städten wie zum Beispiel in Madrid aber
auch wieder Randale wieder in Brüssel
die Polizei rückte an es gab mehrere
Festnahmen
und ganz aktuell soeben gemeldet die
dfl-chefin Donata Hopfen muss gehen also
es gibt offensichtlich einige
strukturelle Probleme im deutschen
Fußball auch eine Art kleines Beben
vielen Dank Christin wir hätten jetzt
noch die Zahlen vom Mittwochslotto für
die für sie und die gehen so 4 14 16 30
37 39 die Superzahl lautet 8 und alles
zum Nachlesen auf lotto.zdf.de oder auf
der zdf-textseite 557
ja es bleibt winterlich mehr dazu gleich
von Katja horneffer der Präsident des
Bundeskriminalamtes Münch im heute
journal Interview mit Marietta Slomka ab
kurz vor 10 hier geht es gleich weiter
mit dem ZDF Spezial zur Razzia in der
reichsbürgersszene das war es von uns
wir sagen schönen Dank schönen Abend und
bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute gab es mal
Sonnenschein im Norden im Westen und
auch im Süden Deutschlands und es zogen
Schauer über uns hinweg Blau das ist
Regen und rosa ist Schnee heute Nacht
setzt neuer Schneefall von Nordwesten
ein und es kann auch mal für
Wintergewitter reichen zwei bis fünf
Zentimeter Neuschnee sind möglich
örtlich vielleicht sogar zehn machen Sie
sich also auf tief winterliche
Straßenverhältnisse gefasst im Süden
bleibt es dagegen trocken der blitzt
sich Nebel da sinken die Werte bis -7
Grad und morgen ziehen die Schneefälle
weiter nach Osten es gibt weitere
Schauer freundlicher ist es ganz im
Norden und im Süden bei Temperaturen von
0 bis 5 Grad und kalt geht's in den
nächsten Tagen auch weiter guten Abend